a key witness who allegedly appears in
three sex tapes with our Kelly is now
cooperating with investigators in the
musician sex crimes case
Kelly pleaded not guilty in court
yesterday he was denied release on bond
Adriana Diaz is outside the Correctional
Center in Chicago that's where Kelly is
being held right now
Adriana so how is his witness
cooperating exactly good morning Gail
well she testified under oath
identifying r kelly as the man sexually
abusing her in three videos two of which
were not used as evidence in his 2008
trial kelly was acquitted in 2008 after
that same witness who was 14 at the time
of the alleged crimes did not take the
stand now she and at least 11 others are
cooperating with prosecutors we were in
the courtroom yesterday when Kelly
pleaded not guilty to new federal
charges that he made sex tapes with
minors conspired with associates to
cover them up and paid hush money
prosecutors repeatedly called him a
danger to society to try to get bond
Kelly's lawyers argued he has no current
contact with minors is not a flight risk
because he turned over his passport and
has quote no criminal record his crisis
manager says they will appeal the
judge's decision to deny bond meanwhile
Kelly is being held here in federal
prison which has slits for windows he's
in isolation in a special unit reserved
for high-risk inmates he also faces
federal charges in New York and could
have to appear in person there his next
court appearance here in Chicago is set
for early September
Anthony Adriana thank you